à
[Musique]
smith international de palaiseau
d'accueillir à 1400 élèves avec une
fonction internationale donc des classes
préparatoires mais aussi donc du lycée
général international et 80 logements
donc personnes qui pourront dormir des
étudiants qui pourront dormir sur place
le but de la dimension internationale
c'est aussi à beaucoup de chercheurs qui
vont qui habite son plateau de saclay
pour que leur enfant ait plus besoin
d'aller loin et et puissent avoir leurs
enfants qui sont sur place là on est en
décembre 2019
le chantier a commencé le 1er octobre
après une signature du contrat en avril
2019 toujours et donc les prochaines
étapes sont maintenant c'est et
réalisation du gros oeuvre
actuellement c'est un grand trou on va
monter le béton on va on va fermer tout
ça ça sera à peu près au printemps de
l'année prochaine
2020 puis après on va travailler sur les
réalisations intérieur jusque jusqu'au
printemps 2021 pour une rentrée
septembre 2021 donc les élèves seront
accueillis en septembre des u21 pour
nous c'était un projet exceptionnel
exceptionnel par sa situation
exceptionnelle par sa taille et
ce qui est bien sûr induisait des grands
enjeux alors l'enjeu de l'intégration de
ce projet dans le futur plateau de
saclay de la parcelle est une parcelle
qui fait 100 mètres de côté et qui est
située à l'intersection entre deux
éléments majeurs de la conception
urbaine du projet à savoir la maille
piétons qui est un axe fédérateur
horizontal et puis ta trame de l'école
polytechnique la portion de territoire
qui va absorber cette affection
s'appelle le green
pour nous ça a été un grand plaisir de
travailler ce projet avec on dire avec
cette recherche d'évidence de lisibilité
des composantes de clarté de la
composition
et puis aussi la proposition de faire à
l'angle côté sud ouest de l'opération à
bâtiment trou qui va recevoir plus des
fonctions annexes de deux lycées
administration locaux des professeurs
cdi et ce bâtiment prouve à être dans la
perspective du maï et va signifier la
présence de l'équipement et valoriser
l'apprentissage du savoir
[Musique]